folks this just in over the wire we got
a hot new merch drop get back drop baby
from november 8th to november 18th you
can get your limited edition toddy's
goodies we're asking everyone to remain
calm
we're gonna have a real black friday
situation on our hands we got bernie's
teas and hoodies we got hoodies tees we
got hoodies tees and hoodies we got
bunkos we got bonkos tees and hoodies
guys uh the link will be in the
description go to bonfire.com
are you garbage limited edition only
available for 10 or 11 days get them
while they're available get the holiday
orders in now welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey
[Music]
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r.u garbage
it's a little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out they
grow up to be classy or if they're just
a big old piece of trash i'm your host h
foley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're down here once again today's time
share down here in houston texas we're
having a good time i saw her this
morning yeah stealing an omelet from the
buffet at the hotel oh man turned her in
wanted to be a good guest you know what
i mean maybe get a couple of points
coming my way did they upgrade the room
at all they did they kicked her out
but now she's staying with me so i'm
screwed again it's a win-win my co-host
is coming at you from right next to me
he is the ceo of are you garbage he's
really an international businessman to
be honest with you not to be trifled
with in the boardroom but here on
vacation he lets his hair down a little
bit he has a couple of pops he's
enjoying himself spending that credit
card real nice too you're throwing that
thing around like it's nickels i love it
kevin james ryan hey gang happy to be
here as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube and as you know
those numbers are true they're [ __ ]
cooking and then patreon.com the
greatest goddamn website ever made shout
out
www.patreon.com charlie garbage check
out the party that's going on over there
amen millions and millions upon millions
of hours bonus content
all available on the site as a whole not
ads
there's about 80 there and how about a
nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man he makes us
all look good also doing a great job
having an amazing time down here in
houston
tebow mcmuffin
it's toby mcmullen oh what's up dudes
i'm about to get a face tattoo i'm
[ __ ] radicalized skank fest has
changed me dude t-bone t-bone's
recording this episode with no shoes or
socks on right now it's crazy we got a
different vibe down here houston dog
turned into a hillbilly i like it
ah yeah give me some dear corn and some
cannabis but i'll tell you this we got a
little company in the house a very good
friend of ours
we could not be more excited to have our
incredibly special guest
back with us again today official family
member in person for the first time in
person for the first time look at that
on vacation with us that's family right
real family stuff he uh he has an
amazing podcast called jeremiah wonders
he also has an amazing podcast called
scissor bros
and then he has something else out right
now that i can't quite remember
he's the voice of
the [ __ ] joker oh
he's the [ __ ] joker
on the new animated series the joker
ladies and gentlemen give it up for mr
jeremiah watkins what's up guys
what's up bro party let's run down that
list nicholson
leto
watkins cesar romero
is it too much if i make a collage
and post it on instagram and just be
like
[Music]
[Laughter]
who was your who was your
picture you in the shower at the end
not a professional shot at all
yeah
well caesar romero you can see the
mustache though yeah it's all good isn't
that weird back in the day when the guys
had they they love their mustache too
much where they're like just paint over
it yeah
i can never regrow this kid too much
it's part of me i don't wanna
you see people host like snl and stuff
and you're like you're really not gonna
shave yeah just do it for the sketch
show yeah we'll be back in a couple of
weeks yeah i don't care about the
project i'm going to score some [ __ ] on
rodeo later i hear that after party's
hot
i'm going up against burt reynolds i
need a stash
buddy how the hell are you man dude i'm
so good i'm so excited to be here i
follow you guys so closely
online on your social medias and
everything and i love i love tweeting at
you guys i love tagging you we have a
good time we were talking about it
yesterday we did i did a little brief
little segment on his pod that he has
and uh we were talking about how
the stuff that he tags us in
a lot of times
is like insane level of garbage
yeah man you can uh as
i'm a big fat pig we all agree on that
sure right uh you're watching
amaze me i go for it you go i found that
you and i share similar taste buds yes
and what i like about it but not
waistlines
i like about it is you have a you have a
you have a wide palate so when you go in
it's wild there's there's like there's
like chinese spare ribs there's lasagna
there's a [ __ ] chocolate cake there's
a gallon of milk there's a gatorade a
bottle of pedialyte
it's [ __ ] dude it's like you spend
like 400 on a meal in a hotel room
that's what it looks like i'm just a
pregnant woman at all
my palate is like i'm like i'm about to
have a baby but it never came out kid's
got hot flashes get him some kimchi
quick go for it freak out over here yeah
i just found out that not everybody has
diarrhea everywhere
well here on this pod we do
i just want to clarify that i literally
thought that was tuesday forever
[Laughter]
how's uh how's the family life has the
baby and all that stuff dude it's
awesome it's a it's a cool it's just a
cool new chapter being a dad it really
is it's just like
life was like this cool thing before now
it's like this new fun addition that's
really all that's how i look at it
that's fantastic what a [ __ ]
perspective on this kid i know i imagine
you're gonna have a good ride too
because you're a child at heart oh dude
i'm excited to introduce my son to the
action figures that i like and the
movies and the comic books and she
already watched goonies six times yeah
he watched hocus pocus the other day
stardom young baby yeah stardom young
yeah um now are you gonna or do you
think you have to are you gonna eat like
that in front of your kid you think i
can't you can't right except one month
you can't be like hey eat your green
beans dad's having three domino's pizzas
yeah dude that's not that's not
happening
why does daddy get to have ice cream for
dinner
because daddy works
because daddy pays the bills around here
have you ever heard of the joker
nicholson
daddy did eight shows in kansas city
last weekend so we can have a little
treat yeah yeah that's fantastic we're
just like our parents ship like our dads
but we like we like little kid stuff too
you know what i mean like yeah you gotta
eat your vegetables yeah yeah meanwhile
my dad was eating cereal out of a
tupperware thing i was eating [ __ ]
green beans
all right so we got some questions here
yeah so i don't know if you know when
you when you sign up for the patreon we
will answer your garbage question on the
air uh and they got some [ __ ] heaters
they're always they've learned it's like
hive mind like they've learned even how
to phrase them how we asked them it's
like really good um this one's from
uh salami hussein i don't know if that's
his government name or not uh
have you were you or any of your friends
the kid who ever pulled the fire alarm
ooh
that was a bad game i could see that
i never did that i think one of my
buddies might have i had a buddy he was
the kid who pooped in urinals oh
man you say that like there's one in
every school
talk about taking it up a notch
you're talking about talking about a pin
on your teacher's seat this guy's taking
deuces in the principal's office
what the [ __ ] i mean that was his go-to
that is hilarious
how old are we talking dude this is
junior and senior year
in high school because one of my best
friends in high school he got voted
class clown
this was in law school
yeah dude that's i was always
in school he would do it or just like
anywhere you guys went no he would just
do it at school i think it was just like
a rebellious like screw you but the
thing that's the worst about that is
like the teachers don't even have to
deal with it's a freaking custodian yeah
it's not yeah it's like you're pranking
the wrong person yeah the guy really
it's just the teacher walking in and
being like hey i have an incident down
in men's room
and the guy most likely could be a
serial killer who the yeah you don't
want any ornamental you never [ __ ]
with that guy you never [ __ ] up the
custodian no oh no he was like the candy
man yeah i remember we had it was where
we had one who would like it wasn't like
junior high and he would like he was
like this younger guy and like all the
girls would like you know flirt with and
he would flirt back do you last like
he lasted like 48 hours before they're
like get this guy the [ __ ] out who did a
background check on this thing this is a
lawsuit waiting dude he was flirting
with the girls like immediately i'm like
you didn't even like wait to [ __ ]
settle down at all you're still on
probation i'll talk to you guys later i
gotta go clean up a dump in the urinals
jeremiah's boy pooped in a urinal again
i find his little prick i'ma break his
[ __ ] neck
he's doing bits like i gotta put kitty
litter down because all these [ __ ]
are wet
come on it's a family toby we're on
vacation god damn it put some shoes on
if you're gonna make jokes like that
chews off toby
rules
even his feet go wrong
toby mad dog
this guy's toby smash yeah
i was always scared of the ink that they
told you that was in there and the fire
alarm i don't know if that's my
generation or your generation it's the
same thing like with bank bags and stuff
like that like that's real though
right
yeah they said when you pulled it down
that ink would shoot out on you and you
would have it on your shirt and then you
would be able to tell they'd be able to
tell
is that a real thing it's folklore but
there was there was the reason they got
away with it there was a little tiny
that's a real thing okay well the next
i'm not robbing any banks anytime soon
blow a pack in your face
but the pool was one that was a myth too
right the red the red dye and the pool
that followed your arsenal or whatever
yeah we talked about that that's that
can't be real there's no way no i would
have seen it for sure somewhere
somebody's pool
i've peed in every we've talked about
this i peed in most pools if not every
pool i've ever been in absolutely ever
right do you pee in the pool no i'll go
really oh ocean for sure yeah yeah i'll
dump in an ocean that's like a urinal
your boy's dumping in the urinals hey
don't pee in the pool let's go man
that's why he got class clown
[Laughter]
some guys are about that life you know
what happened you're like that's why i
do different trajectory
chasing i'm avenging
that's fantastic all right this one's
from zach ever run out of gas while
driving
yeah really really what are you you're
in la so you probably have a car right
so this happened a couple times
one time
i was pushing it to the limit and i ran
out of gas pulling into or driving
pulling out of my driveway to go get gas
do you have a digital like thing that
was this no it was a 98 acura cl uh
sports edition
it's actually not a bad piece of it i am
the joker at the end of the day don't
you forget
i'm not not driving around in a sports
edition paint it lime green pipe bombs
inside
i had uh it on e but it was one of those
things where
you know on older cars it's not dialed
in
i started to pull out of the driveway to
go get gas was right around the corner
and i had to ask my roommate at the time
to push my car back in the driveway i
had to walk around the block get gas and
then come back in
and then one time we were driving from
la to austin to do gigs for south by
southwest
and one of the guys who was in charge of
driving the van everybody else is asleep
in the back and then the the the van
starts
puttering it starts puttering and then i
just hear uh-oh
and we're the van driver yeah we're
stranded on the side of the highway in
the middle of texas
and we had a guy come by
that's how you get killed oh i know a
guy came by with his wife in a in a
tanker truck that had a bunch of gas in
the back of it and he goes what he goes
you boys out of gas
i think he's threatening you and i and i
was like uh
yeah
all right you kiss you
have that tall one take his shirt off
start undressing man you want half a
gallon let me see the tip of your dick
my wife likes to watch
dude he was like i'll charge you guys uh
60 dollars a gallon for gas what no
we're like what he goes he goes if you
get three gallons it'll it'll get you
that next down that's how far you are
from the next town and we were like
we'll just wait on triple a yeah and
that guy apparently well that's what he
does for a living i am he goes up and
down the highway charges people up the
butt for just like paying gas because
they need it in that moment damn wow
because he literally goes he goes all
right and then he's like kind of
probably like off to the next [ __ ] i'm
gonna take advantage of holy [ __ ] yeah
that lady really landed herself a
[ __ ] winner i looked at her i looked
at her like ma'am are you gonna do
anything like that she's like so you're
going to buy
i was going on 70 smart ass yeah yeah
holy [ __ ] yeah that's [ __ ] dirtbag
[ __ ] yeah that's like from uh breakdown
that kurt russell movie back in the day
for all you know that guy could have
[ __ ] emptied your tank at the last
gas station where you guys were sleeping
yeah i've always wanted to do that i've
seen it in movies but yeah i've seen my
step dad do it talk about a garbage can
yeah he gets in there ugh he's can't
imagine what gas tastes like he's a real
redneck so it's like
it's just that's i mean he'll do it with
like coolant or if like a hose goes
yeah at one point he was like siphoning
stuff my engine wasn't working and he
came and picked me up and at one point
dude he had he had a tube in his mouth
and he's like all right turn it i'm like
what
he was part of the car at one point he's
doing it at the parking lot at school
yeah
i'm definitely just crazy no i'm not
going to prom you idiot if i ever get
bit by a snake i'm hanging out him
somebody called kippy's stepdad
that was always crazy he sucked the
poison out no way that works
no way i think if worse comes i can't
it's better
i guess i don't know you spit real quick
you get it out that and paint on someone
with the jellyfish thing those are like
those lures of like if you get you know
stunned by a jellyfish you peon would
you be able to do it pee on a friend
they'd have to close their eyes they
don't like show them my unit you know
i'd be like sorry man i don't have to go
i'm sorry i just went in the water with
jeremiah oh man yeah
no thank you i'm gonna pull my little my
little minnow out on that beach
especially that cold water yeah
not a good mix no well crabby jump up
and get me that was just one weird guy
who got hit with a jellyfish like what
do we do he's like ah
yeah that'll solve it right
you figure my ass why people oh no that
feels much better
oh they should we're gonna put this in a
book this is great yeah yeah this is
great a scientist is there he's like i
guess this works yeah he's like we're in
kansas where there are no jellyfish
i think i could talk about jellybeans oh
one of those lake jellyfish is got me
he's out
he's at work i think i got stung someone
get me
got these shower jellyfish all over me
they're killing me shower jellyfish for
real i got one of those hotel jellyfish
it's a rare breed but they're very
poisonous they're in the mattresses
[Laughter]
man we're having a good time we're
having a good time here on vacation
don't be a bozo subscribe on patreon
garbage today become a homie yeah um my
new moose knuckle's probably sticking
out
the lounge look isn't the best for me
it's not yeah i'm not a daytime kind of
guy
you got the limp biscuit look cooking
yeah yeah this is the very uh the nookie
uh outfit he worked cargos backwards red
hat i don't know if there's cards
black shirts that's what i should start
rocking yeah red backwards
hat yeah yeah yeah there we go go full
thirst yeah yeah coming back it's coming
back hard limp biz quick over here
man
that is a good piece of business that's
why he's a joker ladies and gentlemen
holy [ __ ]
i did it all for the waffles the waffles
oh man
[Laughter]
the joke is
the joke is clearly cooking
the radio edit was cookie i did it for
the cookie the what i had i had the
unedited version i don't know about you
you [ __ ] loser
i was a lot of listen to cusses just
bombed in front of the joker
well i'll be ripped to shreds for sure
[Laughter]
um all right this one's from
uh chad shout out to chad i haven't had
a question yet you ever buy meat from
the dollar store
oh yeah really
yeah
is it a dollar or is it just is it like
three dollars
i don't know what kind of meat you could
get that's what they get okay so this
this is the kind of meat and i still
i've upgraded a little bit over the
years but i'm sorry defined dollar store
though like dollar store is
truly a dollar you're talking in los
angeles in los angeles even in los
angeles is it dollar general it's a
dollar
sometimes there's dollar trees there's
dollar generals and then dollar tree
uh
and then there's uh
there's other off-brand um i forget the
names of some of the off-brand uh other
dollar stores that i've shopped i think
dollar tree is pretty good to
wait they don't have a deli jeremiah
that's
a deli
i call it deli a taco dude excuse me
these rolls fresh yeah do you have any
kosher pickles back there
it's not you don't walk in and there's
like salami there's just a guy with one
of those machines and it's just packaged
goods falling out of the bottom of it
he's trimming pencils or something yeah
yeah
weird birthday candles are falling out
dude dollar tree gets real creepy yeah
so it's usually a dollar or some of
those dollar places are like 1.59 or
something like that you know they're
like up a little bit sure uh but i've
definitely gotten dollar store uh meat
before what i have to like ground beef
or something what are we talking about
no a lot of turkeys hams uh baloneys
different stuff like pre-sliced meat you
mean yeah that'll give you like oscar
mayer yeah i don't know if i've gotten
yeah i've gotten hot dogs and stuff like
that but i've got i've never gotten
ground beef
i don't even know if they sell there i'd
be surprised because i probably already
would have bought it i'm a little upset
i've never come across yeah but what you
got to do with cheaper meat is because
it's so sweaty is you gotta take two
pieces of paper towels
so i can absorb all of the excrement
that's on the outside of it and then you
have to give yourself a good sandwich oh
god i hate you holy [ __ ] you gotta boil
it first
kill the germs yeah you gotta put it out
in the sun for about three hours you
gotta let it sun you gotta sun dry
baloney is that what you got oh you
gotta put on some clothespins outside
fresh linen yeah
that's
you got to pat it down before you put it
in your mouth
[Music]
i would wash it before
i've never thought of that yeah wash it
all you never washed off chicken or
anything like that before you put it on
yeah he's talking about like bologna
sandwiches though he can't be washing
the ground beef that's disgusting no no
it's just like like thin slices of meat
you gotta pat it down with paper towels
because it has like little as extra
little white stuff on top
yeah
i think how so he said it like so cute
extra little white stuff
those are the worms trying to get out
let's talk about our good friends at
butcher butcher box i got a meat full of
i got a freezer full of meat
courtesy of these good people best guys
over there and gals the best guys over
there and gals they send top quality
meat right to your door you gotta get on
it you will not regret it yeah holidays
coming around you can't be a bozo with
you know meat from the supermarket go
high-end get the good stuff the good
stuff grass-fed grow some socks off of
your neighbors are coming over you got
your aunt your uncle your cousin you
don't like you know let them know what's
up flex on them a little bit with some
good meat all right butcher box every
month butcherbox ships a curated
selection of high quality meat right to
your home
free shipping for the continental u.s of
a no no antibiotics no hormones each box
contains 8 to 14 pounds of meat
depending on the box you choose that's
enough for 24 individual meals baby
butcher boxes offering new members 20
off and free bacon in your first box
what free bacon what happened to the
ground beef when i was doing bacon
that's how good these guys are you know
we're going to be a bozo who goes to the
store and buys bacon these guys are
giving it out for free
it's good stuff this offer is ending 11
21 so get this deal before it's gone
sign up at butcherbox.com ayg that's
butcherbox.com ayg to get free bacon and
20 bucks off your first box do it yeah
expressvpn kippy the best
expressvpn
vpn
very important express they got the best
one you want to get on top of it you
don't want to be
going out there on the internet with
everything hanging out there you want to
do it privately and securely
expressvpn can help yeah guys as you
know you know uh
the protection of your information uh
you know you're all robbing you they're
stealing they're pulling a wool over
your eyes taking your information
harvesting it sending it out to big
companies and you're the chump sitting
there not getting paid everybody's
wetting their beak on your info except
you
um so it turns out even the incognito
mode on your browser uh still let your
online activity be seen tracked and sold
but with expressvpn your connection gets
rerouted to an encrypted server and your
ip address is masked every time you
connect
uh to expressvpn you get a random ip
address shared by many other users of
expressvpn it makes it harder for third
parties to identify and harvest your
data i'm in hoffenfrau i'm in albany i'm
in syracuse who knows they don't know
that's the best part they don't know so
if you really want to go incognito mode
protect your privacy secure yourself
with the number one rated vpn visit
expressvpn.com garbage and get three
extra months for free that's expressvpn
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n.com
garbage go to expressvpn.com garbage to
learn more do it oh [ __ ] that's i the
only the the lowest i've done was
uh over the pandemic i was staying at uh
my family's uh vacation house down on
the jersey shore for the whole time and
at that uh supermarket there was a
bargain bin
meat like you know it was just like a
cooler you would open up and it was
chicken parts you can get chicken parts
one turkey it was like everything was
like everything felt like it had been
frozen for like 35 years it took forever
to fall out everything burned and yeah
it was not a good look yeah when you get
those chicken parts it you always get
the vibe that they're not all from the
same chicken even if it's just like two
drumsticks yeah it's like a mob head
yeah it's like frankenstein you pieced
this together yeah there was like a
drive-by that happened
like the bottom part yeah it's gonna
wing from here throw it in the bag and
get it in the cooler yeah how do you
guys feel about people who pat down
their pizza like you'd always see people
doing that back in the day i get i get
it you know especially if it makes it
easier to eat you know if it dries it
out a bit i'm not a fan of it because if
you have made this decision you got to
go all in and i'm the kind i'm the kind
of guy who goes like this
let it drip in yeah are you looking at
me are you crazy you know my answer is
extra grease yeah i'm with the kid over
here yeah the only way i could see that
is when you're doing the walking slice
it'll drip down back and you can't tell
when that shit's [ __ ] i know going
down going all the way down dude it's
burnt because it's perfect it's it's the
exact same temperature as you are
it's like molding to you like a symbiote
that's why i like it i'm almost fully
pizza
that's that's his venom origin story is
this like like the juice of pizza and
it's like it's all cheese that's going
over his body hey we put dollar store
meat on the pizza give it to the fat kid
leaking into my blood
god damn um i don't even like the
pre-sliced lunch meat i won't even do
that yeah i get like the fresh you have
to get the cut yeah i gotta go cut
sliced in american cheese slice thin nah
hillshire farms makes a nice little
thing that almost looks like uh like one
of those like tupperware things yeah
it's got the red top or whatever yeah
they ain't bad do you do craft singles
ever the cheese oh yeah yeah
they're so great solo in half right in
there
you know it's a nice little treat for
you kids out there that and doritos
cheese slice craft singles and doritos
wow i've had it with a screamer screamer
coca-cola
i would never even get to that point
where i was i would just eat the whole
bag of doritos not have a little cheese
you never know it never crossed my mind
you ever melted the craft cheese on
tortilla chips or the dorito chips in
the microwave
yeah yeah yeah yeah i've been making
bootleg nachos for a long time oh dude i
think
using pretzels chips
i used to make uh seven layer nachos for
my mom and i and then now i do it for my
wife upgrade
not bragging
now we're doing nine layers yeah dude
and you make them in the microwave uh
it's a whole thing i i'll put uh the
tostitos uh cheese uh queso on the stove
oh that's the best and that's the best
that is the best so good and then i'll
have uh like either a mexican cheese or
like a sharp cheddar like uh to put on
top refried beans jalapenos uh and like
uh with different um like either
habanero sauce or a salsa uh
and uh usually that's about it yeah like
all like spread over it that's really
good we gotta take a break i'm getting
it yeah right god damn that's good yeah
talk about trash i love it i remember
when i figured out to do that because
like i was always home alone from school
by myself and like there would be some
food but not much i was like oh i got i
got the tortilla chips right and i was
like i got america you know i got craft
singles and i was like i'm i think i'm
the smartest man alive
or the fattest kid or the fattest lonely
kid ever that's where garbage tendencies
come from at home there's not you got to
think on your feet yeah oh yeah you got
to make a hodgepodge got everything you
got to go outside the box oh yeah i used
to do uh spaghetti like like boiled
spaghetti with a can of cream of
mushroom soup
ooh
not too shallow aristocrat
and a glass of white wine
a nice pairing yeah sauvignon blanc now
how do you feel you i would assume
you're a big fan how do you feel about
the spray cheese i love it
i love it he's trash
yeah i would get jealous uh when i would
see that in movies like as a kid when uh
somebody'd have a cheese can they'd go
right out of my mouth i can't wait to do
that someday when i have money
[Laughter]
get my [ __ ] act together and get some
of that goddamn spray cheese yeah i've
been delivering paper saving up to get a
little cheese whiz
that's been that's been a constant in my
house we constantly have there's
multiple flavors we have like every
flavor and always have for like 20 years
there's more flavors yeah there's like
uh we're a little fancy uh there's like
a a port wine there's like a port wine
cheese or something there's nacho
cheddar a nacho cheddar then there's a
red cap one
i think or like a dark red i thought
there was only that sharp cheddar one no
there's multiple
there's been a lot of innovations here
yeah the canned cheese people got their
[ __ ] act together they're really
turning the industry upside down dude
they need a vending machine with canned
cheese
how dope would that be
cold or warm
either way i mean if you keep it warm
crack it open ice cold wait you keep
yours in the fridge you have to you have
to no it's not it's in the
pantry once you open it do you have to
put it in the fridge i think we put it
in the fridge the top hardens up and it
makes this little like [ __ ] ah
that makes it so it's self-sealing did
you ever accidentally put that on the
chip and then you ate the crunch oh it's
the worst yeah it's a hard piece of
cheese is weird yeah it's right when a
little air gets it you go in there just
on the ends yeah
this is not the best year of chase
what is this a 98
yeah um all right let's see
this is from jono have you ever used
tape and tissues as a band-aid
i have a lot that's a big like
construction site type thing right like
i've definitely done that yeah yeah
let's [ __ ] tape it up have to so but
you ever do super glue i was just gonna
ask you that you ever super glue
something i've never done super glue no
yeah
it's hardcore yeah yeah yeah that's real
that's like vietnam [ __ ] that's like
mechanic [ __ ] yeah it's a little
superglue that's like real rough around
the edges oh i assume we'd say when
you're about to bleed out that's when
you go to that
family members that just that's what
they do i did it like seven months ago
yeah really for what was the injury i i
was
getting a pit of an avocado and the
knife went through the pit and into my
thumb slices [ __ ] on my thumb and the
pandemic was cooking i didn't want to go
to a hospital bleeding all over sam's
parents place like you got any super
glue they're like what yeah it's a
pandemic [ __ ] go get it
that's crazy it's gonna get for a little
while
i feel like that would not be good for
the blood like that's like putting the
way to seal it yeah i don't know it's it
was literally invented for that for
vietnam to be used in the battlefield to
heal up wounds super glue was that is
correct jesus
wow damn those guys are hardcore
people who went to vietnam yeah
that is hardcore they don't have cheese
until this until this day he's like hey
you know those wimps who went to vietnam
yeah wait they were super gluing
themselves these guys are nuts
because they're bonkers agent orange
whatever super glue yeah
that's hardcore man um all right there's
one that's been on the pod uh recently
uh the pants
and
uh
socks what goes on first pants or socks
or give us the whole dress yeah start
the show get out of the shower start the
shower we're on vacation here come on
cause there's another one someone else
roll one in that's in this same world
it's gonna be very divisive i put on
boxers first
[Music]
uh then boxer briefs first then i put on
uh sheaths i hope
yeah
well that was that's my favorite pair
too oh that's a good yeah that's a good
one that's a good one uh
and then i put on the shirt then i put
on the pants i put on my socks last yes
cause he's a smart gentleman that's why
i put on my socks last because i feel
weird like having the socks on already
as they slink through the pant leg
it feels like weird to me that's a good
feeling i don't like crazy i like my
tootsies out and about until i'm ready
to put them in a shoe yeah i it'll be
the la sometimes i'll put my socks right
next to my shoes by the door and i'll
literally put them on like because
sometimes i'll sleep in socks
what yeah sometimes i sleep in socks i
can't get a read on this guy you don't
sleep in socks and then then just throw
the shoes on and go on about the day
there no i'll shout out night night
socks and no my hair well it depends so
i'll i usually shower at night before i
go out for the night and then like the
rest of the day i'll be in from the
outfit from the night before right and
then you're sleeping those socks get up
take them off yeah yeah all right that
makes sense yeah that that that'll give
you you so every day you sleep with your
socks on uh it depends sometimes i do so
the the reason why i put up my socks
last is because i'm letting my toesies
air out yeah from the night before well
that's what the evening's for that's
what the night's for yeah that's why you
should be doing that that's apparently
that's why ladies are not supposed to
wear panties to bed really
let things air out that's why it doesn't
get
it's just like
it's just like a foot you're not
supposed to
put socks on
real thing that's what i heard let a
breeze get in there yeah i mean gotta
let it breathe a little bit like nice
wine yeah wear a kilt or something
[Laughter]
cool it off a little bit
um
because this one is do you unleash this
is from will do you unleash your shoes
to put them on or do you just
wedge your foot in and then like slowly
ruin the back of the shoe
do you
untie and tie your shoes every day or
what's what's your what's your steez i
do but i'm uh i like to keep my shoes
clean i wore like rough shoes to skank
fest because like i just wore my vans
just because i knew that there was going
to be a lot of walking around something
like i'm not ruining like a good pair of
shoes sure of course so like i i'll tie
my shoes every time yeah yeah
he's a sharp kid he is sharp dresser
cool guy trash but sharp kit yeah yeah
he tries to sharp yeah i don't die
never
the shoes are an issue for you yeah i'm
not tying anything no i just wait in
there
that's how i determine when when i go to
the uh when i go to dicks to get my
sneakies i make sure that i can do that
because if i can you still are you still
like treating like the 90s do you have
them like put them on for you and stuff
the guy ties them pumps them up i make
him measure my foot every time well
yep it's a 32 wide yeah you go in you're
like and the guy's like every time he's
measured like how does this guy not know
his shoe size
he's like holy it's an 11 i know yeah
you're 45 your feet aren't growing
he's going to payless asking for the
usual
get the shoehorn out sit there that
little bench and at the little mirror on
it do the whole work looking down
yeah
we're looking at them from that mirror
even though like we never look at it
yeah yeah yeah are we looking at it from
like way down here yeah walking around
with one on two doing that like yeah but
you're always like i think i could like
this yeah what i mean is it comfy could
this be me could i be this guy yeah you
feel like a [ __ ] idiot my mom was
real aggressive with the toe check too
oh man she'd [ __ ] pop a nail on you
yeah
dude
yeah
that's it it was like playing videos
right there
because she she wanted to make sure
there was about like a good almost thing
to get her money's worth oh you got to
grow into it yeah she wanted she wanted
a thumbs worth yeah [ __ ] tucking my
toes back
yeah scrunching them off yeah yeah they
look like elf shoes by the time she's
done with them she's like rolling them
back on your okay these are the ones
honey they're pointing back basically
are these aladdin shoes what are these
you'll get another pair in college that
and then
back to school shopping tools you would
i would get like up until like a certain
age you'd be like how's it in the crotch
and i'm like all right yeah you're done
you're done you're done now yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah there's a little bit of
fuzz down there keep it moving all right
can't be getting handsy in the green
room my mom walking in where's the husky
section
really yeah yeah
yeah streaming
chubby kid really yeah i stretched out
husky tough skin all day yeah everything
was reinforced i was like a mandalorian
[ __ ]
knee pads [ __ ] everything and you're
like this is the way yeah you're dressed
like a welder
[Laughter]
fully driving a locomotive later what's
happening these are those duluths what
the [ __ ] is that
um
this one's from misty did you ever own a
no fear shirt in the 90s absolutely
i had a uh one of my favorite shirts in
the 90s was a no fear uh taz tasmanian
devil shirt that i had wow
wow he was huge man i had this um this
lucky hat that i wore for years uh there
was like a tazz uh as well like no i
think it was a no fear as well uh hat
that i wore as a as a goalie for soccer
that was like my good luck hat that was
like always get a ton of saves like when
i wore that hat
wait wait you're in goal with a
tasmanian devil hat on
my what you were wearing it on the field
oh yeah
that's crazy goalie though what goals
always play by their own rules goalies
can wear hats like i mean i don't know
like like professionally i don't think
that that's a thing but like one of your
traditional teams
yeah when you're a kid you could wear uh
and i play premiere and everything i
could wear hats as a goalie
any hat any hat i wanted you wearing a
bet's hat
[Laughter]
nice try hot shot get that out of here
you're dang tootin i'm gonna save this
bob uh watkins lets another goal in
the beekeeper mask was probably a
mistake
you got the fencing mask on
yeah exactly
[Laughter]
a little weird uh watkins has a turban
on today in the midwest
interesting choice for a goalie hat
watkins going with the british safari
hat today very classy
in honor of the queen's birthday
i should have wore a jester hat just to
mess with people
they were big in the 90s too no mouth
guard just a pacifier yeah
ghost things you didn't get it past the
baby looks like you're leaving a rave
[Laughter]
the chief started the baby in goal again
brooke linen brook lennon brook linen
classy very classiest quality betting
you want to feel a little bit better go
brook linen baby i feel like you're a
millionaire laying in these sheets an
easy easy way to feel like a millionaire
unbelievable gang you got to check out
brooklyn fantastic products support the
companies that support this podcast it's
not like they're huge huge companies all
right
they're good people nice people support
them yeah get some brooklyn and sheets
baby you won't regret it they got it all
they got sheets all high-quality home
essentials you can sleep like royalty in
these shoes they sent us they sent me
and my lady uh some of the towels dude
i'm telling you i get out i'm typically
a guy who gets out dried off real quick
throw on clothes now i wrap it around my
chest watching your side i wrap my hair
in one i'm walking around so you're
drying yourself with a cloud feeling
real nice uh brooklyn was started to
create beautiful high quality home
essentials that don't cost an arm and
leg and people guess what let me tell
you home run over there cooking so give
yourself the comfort and refresh you
deserve and get get it for less at
brooklyn go to brooklyn.com use promo
code garbage to get 20 bucks off with a
minimum purchase of a hundo baby
what what are we doing we're giving
these things away benny's that's brook
lennon
b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com and our promo
code garbage for 20 off with minimum
purchase of 100 that's brooklyn.com
promo code garbage one more time as i
stumbled through that that's
brooklyn.com promo code garbage do it
kevin let's talk about decked decked
let's talk about deck if you got a truck
and you got tools and you got this and
you got that in the back of it with the
weather this time of year it's going to
get wet it's going to get cold it's
going to get frozen get stolen it's get
stolen yeah they'll grab your stuff
while you're in there grabbing a cup of
coffee before you head off to the job
site that's why you got to get decked
secure keep your things safe yeah the
deck drawer system is weatherproof so
protects and secures all your stuff from
mother nature who can be a real mother
if you catch my drift oh i feel you um
dect makes organizing accessing
everything much easier uh each of deck's
two
uh full bed length drawers can carry up
to 200 pounds of whatever you got so the
drawers roll out waist high giving you
easy access for your organized tools and
gear fit half of me in there
they they uh the guys attacked were nice
enough they sent uh they sent us one and
obviously we live in the city so i don't
you know but my stepdad gave it to him
this guy who man it's like loves it it's
like hell here's this here's that he's
it's like he's like going around the job
site bragging the other guys look at
this my butt it might be they look great
my boy's got a podcast check out this
cool [ __ ] i got that's what he's doing
he's looking he's like he feels like the
coolest dude he's hanging out at the
wawa y'all check out the drawers you
know he flips the hatchback flex on them
these truck guys love their trucks love
them love them you got a flex on the
other truck guys uh so protect your
stuff like i do like we do with dect get
your decked drawer system at deck.com
garbage and get free shipping that's
dect.com
sorry slash garbage for free shipping
a lot of these in here on your decked
drawer system deck.com garbage now back
to the show back to the show
oh god damn i was no fear you know where
you no fear that had to be hot when you
were cause you were older nah i didn't
[ __ ] with that [ __ ] no fear tap out none
of that stuff maybe you're not the same
oh whoa whoa whoa don't clump those two
together that's all the same to me no
you're nuts there's nine bands named
creed
wow jesus
you know what you have like the
mentality of a 90 year old man what was
the difference between no fear and tap
out for about 20 years to be honest
i mean for starters were they friends
with ed hardy what was the story
dude this is the weirdest family tree
ever
i [ __ ] hate it at hearty oh well i
think yeah cause i could never be that's
roughly that often sure you would never
no no no no
those jeans were something like those
the dragons the bedazzled the all that
no i hated that stuff yeah
i remember thinking i'm like man i hope
this doesn't get to like where i have to
you know what i mean i'm like i hope
this never gets to the point where like
everybody's doing it but me type thing
you got a cowboy hat and a shredded
t-shirt on balding wearing a dragon
t-shirt that's a bad look no i never
[ __ ] with any of that stuff yeah
big johnson was was yeah
what about big dog did you shop a big
dog no who was big dog big dog was for
bigger boys yeah i wore big dog all the
time was it big dogs with a z maybe does
that sound right or was it just big dog
big dogs maybe big dog big dogs is this
this is and they had like witty
yeah we literally my uncle uh we call
him uncle big dog because he
used to all he used to exclusively wear
big dog clothing yeah he like loved it
he had every he had the the dogs playing
poker yeah yeah yeah the dog's at a
barbecue if you ain't a big dog then get
off the porch like those kind of like
graphic tees and stuff like that yeah it
was all kind of like bad at like bad ass
or witty he was like king johnson types
cool looking yeah were they rob no
dalmatians what were they they're like
yeah i forget i know i can picture them
and it said like you would always like
big dogs like here and then like they
had like the picture on the back yeah
yeah yeah damn let's get some [ __ ]
big dogs gear yeah yeah dude i don't
know how i missed that i would have been
all over that oh dude yeah
fat kids
dude what if that was a bra
diabetes it just says fat kids with the
z and it's like trying to be cool
four guys wheezing i'm standing
the little like tommy hilfiger thing is
an inhaler
some kid standing on a broken skateboard
[Laughter]
what a two leader of mountain dew in his
hand
uh we're having a good time this is it
baby down here teddy south for skank
fest south which has been fantastic yeah
as you can tell my voice has been gone
i've smoked 3000 cigarettes in the past
48 hours
caught a couple american spirits
yesterday which usually i would trash
yeah not too shabby though they were
pretty good pretty good this one's just
funny this is from tony p ever buy a
playboy at the airport because if you
are there's that's a bit they don't sell
those anymore at the airport maybe like
the hudson news and stuff holy [ __ ] but
you can't be reading that on a plane
like literature just like
oh the glass is on and everything
or the night like the light up here i
was like oh this is some good reading
can you bring me another blanket sir
[Laughter]
make a little cocoon over top of you
yeah rip out the center fold and tape it
[Laughter]
so we're landing you're gonna have to
remove that
tiffany's got to go
and put your bag back under the seat
seat back he's got it up here like that
he's at summer camp that's [ __ ]
awesome
[Laughter]
that's not i mean i think we might have
touched on this before i would do like
the maxim and stuff before like phones
and like before every tv had like or
every chair had a tv type thing my
brother had a stack of uh like i've
never bought like one at a grocery store
or anything like that but my brother had
a stack of he had
maxim fhm yeah and uh a couple other
like uh what was the other big like gals
and guns or something
something weird something to make you
feel real inadequate while you're taking
a dump yeah brother pretty much yeah
like that's in his bathroom in the
basement just like stack them and i
would be like whoa this is intimidating
yeah yeah it's the maxims they came out
it was a new uh
addition to that
every 35 seconds i swear to god oh yeah
there was billions of them people had
stacks of them everywhere they were hot
you could get like and it gave me like
it was like it was a good thing it was
like you know fashion and tech and stuff
it wasn't just
you know girls yeah if you if you were a
local girl of maxim that was like a girl
that could have gone to school with you
like it was like they were like yeah all
the time yeah yeah one i did go to
school with one of them and it was like
there you go it was like yeah did you
hear about what i don't want to say
what's your name sister and you're like
oh that's all i had to do i got two
copies of the house yeah
hometown hotties or something it was
yeah yeah yeah yeah i think she's going
to harvard next year
no she's bartending you [ __ ] idiot
um all right this one's from sanders
couple of misses
i apologize i'm not used to this
southern air
the altitude is different now i'm all
uncomfortable
you keep looking at me like we're still
doing this like yeah
this guy's out in the left field with a
hockey stick
he's playing goalie with a hat on
give me something to bomb
[Laughter]
give me jokes to bomb
i might bomb this [ __ ] show tonight
give me something bomb i did it all for
the tasty treats oh my god damn it all
right
buddy nothing from before
you know what
how you double downed on your bomb like
oh maybe if i make fun of my other bomb
with a bomb that's what i thought was
gonna do does that ever work
can you can you bomb yourself out of a
bomb
you're trying and it's not working
um all right this one's from sanders do
you or anyone in your family regularly
buy season passes to a water park
were you a water park kid growing up we
had uh well it wasn't year-round passes
but we had worlds of fun and oceans of
fun damn
pretty [ __ ] good they were like
conjoined so if you but you could buy
the more expensive pass and get in where
you could go between the two parks for
the day or all the fun was like roller
like a new proper amusement park exactly
oh i got you yeah this is divided the
water park attached yeah exactly classy
move by the way when they started doing
that oh dude real nice those were those
parks were awesome i never got season
passes to those but it was a big deal if
we went to like one of those theme parks
yeah yeah yeah they were fanta anything
you were afraid to ride what was your
favorite slide
one of my favorite coasters was called
the timberwolf it was one of the last
wooden roller coasters in the world and
uh apparently a few people had died on
that one so it added to the the lore of
going on worse uh one girl this i think
this is an urban legend that got passed
around one one of the girls uh
uh who rode one of the the coasters that
worlds of fun supposedly had really long
hair oh yeah that one you know that
story they did that for great adventure
for a ride called free fall yeah it's
it's like yeah she got it stuck in the
the the the cart behind her and it
ripped off her scalp and then she bled
out in the coaster inside the richard
gere the gerbil thing that's that one's
been everywhere yeah exactly um the
bamboozler was a good one
so they'd knock you out and rob you
eddie baby
i'm [ __ ] back
you're icing me on the [ __ ] bombs um
now i'm back
i thought jeremiah left for a second
i wasn't making that sound the zambezi
zinger was one that's a mouthful it was
a zimbabwe themed roller coaster style
it might have got it cancelled
yeah maybe this isn't the most
culturally appropriate
roller coaster ride i didn't make it out
of 2005. yeah yeah yeah
yeah they were like all right
we got to shut this one down this is
crazy
say it's down for maintenance and just
close it yeah
um i was a shotgun falls man shotgun
falls was the water slide where you
would it would drop like 15 feet like
you know it would go and then you would
just fall into the pool okay kind of
just straight down i was a big lazy
river guy too lazy rivers were fun man
that's the best yeah [ __ ] cruising
around i always felt like a badass like
hopping between tubes and stuff the
anxiety of those places like when you
went up there and like you were scared
and all that stuff i didn't really feel
like it came from the
rides itself that there was nobody there
i would have been okay with it right but
knowing like there's a
slightly older super attractive
lifeguard standing there at the top
watching you and i got my [ __ ] you
know little husky boy oh yeah maybe a
couple of [ __ ] foamies on or
something like that oh man
the swimmies in a swim pool at a water
park is a tough look hold on you were
never a nose plugs kid were you at the
pool no i've got too much going on here
toby were you a nose vlogger no no way
dude dude that's a touch when you jump
in the pool do you hold your nose
i did for years
come on i did dude there's really stayed
up there
that i could die just from the to the
amount that would go up yeah
yeah yeah yeah
that was always there
oh yeah excuse me
yeah i would go around the lazy river
and there would be like a hot lifeguard
that would be like mine my friend's gold
was like who could make that girl laugh
like the hot older girl and then we'd go
around in circles and like see who could
make her laugh on each trip around
that's pretty fun yeah it was a good
game it was a good game damn like dude
you made that hot girl laugh that's
awesome yeah it was too much pressure
and that's what it was for me that we
would always we'd always go to the one
in wildwood new jersey and we'd have to
the thing that he was like climbing i
was [ __ ] petrified of those wooden
stairs climbing up the wooden stairs get
to the top of the water slide
[ __ ] the build up on that because
there was no nothing underneath that
that's what i'm saying
i got bit by a horse fly once on this
one
a horse i was like what the [ __ ] going
on in ocean world
carousels are real i
had oceans of fun on my way up on one of
those wooden walkways up the stairs i
got bit by a horse fly and it hurt
ten times worse than a bee sting for
whatever reason yeah though they can
[ __ ] you up yeah
dude yeah yeah it was nuts i would
always i always liked going on the ones
with the tubes because i could hold the
tube in front of me and like hide my man
you know my little bully boobs
hide behind the mat but you lose that
tube in the in the hole though you're
[ __ ] you look like an idiot coming
out of there you ever have to go and
time out at a public pool
no yeah yeah yeah jesus lay off the
sugar kid holy [ __ ] i went in timeout
for what uh my brother uh was spitting
on
on my friend and i as we went down the
water slide okay and so we're like okay
so when my brother goes down like we're
going to go for it so like me and my
[ __ ] on them
and like the lifeguards are looking like
what are these kids doing and then as
soon as my brother goes down we're like
spitting and they're like you two out of
here and then they laid us like it was
like a corner of shame that we had to
stand in like while we were like sopping
wet like outside the pool like behind a
red line they're like you guys are
sitting in timeout for 15 minutes and
like as a kid that's an eternity oh my
god it's a whole summer right there
christ yeah i remember one time i was
like yeah we're going 45 minutes into my
head i was like 45 15 like 15 hours yeah
45 minutes flying what's it do what the
[ __ ] well you're just looking around
there's nothing to do you're just like
oh man
man i even hate that one i don't know as
an adult like when i when we're walking
somewhere and you know where we're going
exactly
he's he's the worst oh you need to know
exact minutes yeah i need he's going to
complain whether it's one or 18. because
i'm going to cut the same rest if i get
hit with it's a couple blocks down and
i'm three four blocks away i started
losing i had to stop so sometimes i'll
hang out with uh
you know audience members who will come
to shows or whatever where they're like
uh uh they're like oh there's a pool
hall like a couple blocks away i had to
stop
just blindly trusting because a couple
blocks away and something like 20
minutes it's a 20 30 minute walk i'm
like that's not a couple of blocks yeah
yeah now you're on this [ __ ]
excursion with these people you don't
know yeah yeah yeah it's like sometimes
where it's hard to get ubers in certain
cities and stuff it's like well we're
doing this now all right here we go here
we go 15 minutes in there's no turning
back now yeah yeah
oh man uh all right this one's from
frank
uh you you or anyone in your family ever
go to a college that you've learned
about on tv such as itt tech wayo tech
uti et cetera i had a lot of friends go
to go to these things take any online
classes i like the programs you become
an electrician and you know no i didn't
do any trades or anything like that i
mean i got of course
associate of the arts degree from a
community college so
not the brag well you are the joker so
it [ __ ] worked out there you go there
you go god damn i had a couple of
buddies do you know become a computer
programmer and whatever type
thing yeah never really got off heroin
they're still still still struggling
good football team though
[Laughter]
there's a community college somewhere
with a picture of jeremiah dressed as a
cat burglar like our greatest alumni
dude the college that i have an honorary
doctorate degree
a doctorate
from a community college would be epic
dude
i would rock whatever everywhere yeah
dude yeah
if they asked me to come back and speak
at that college i'm going back and
speaking at that community closing with
the joker's voice
class of 2044
it's so nice to be here
place is going nuts
seven people out there
yeah um
it's all on zoom
it was a light semester we didn't get a
lot of people in
um all right let's do one or two more
here uh
we actually did this one yesterday with
uh the other day with josh pratt but it
was funny did you ever get gum stuck in
your hair
yeah
what'd you do well the mess was so dumb
i don't know why i did this i was i was
being 80d in class one day and i was
going like this with my gum i kept going
like this and then i went mm-hmm
[Laughter]
and then the teacher literally i go and
then i go
like it really like i it sunk in like
that i did it to myself yeah and then
the i look at my teacher i go
gum wrapped around i'm an [ __ ] i have
gum my hair can i go to the restroom or
the nurse and he goes yeah he goes i
watched you go like this
and then like this and i saw you do that
and i was like why did he do that and i
go i don't know either and then i had to
go and my friend had to help me hold my
hair while they tried to like pick it
out but they had to cut some of it out
yeah was there a watkins family method a
watkin to to pulling out the the getting
commented
like they did ice ice ice is the big one
i think that gets on your clothes too
like ice you know you're supposed to rub
ice on it yeah that makes sense if you
get stung by a bee it's mud that
happened once
bottom that's not it
no no that's not real come on it's gotta
be real that is not right jeremiah got
bit by a bee put some mud on him and
suck it out throw some dirt on that boy
no dude i got stung by a bee and and my
mom or somebody said put some mud on it
and then like we slapped a bunch of mud
on the because on the bottom of my foot
and like we rubbed it and then the
stinger came out through the mud what
yeah
i don't know holy [ __ ] we've had a lot
of scumbags on this show this might be
the first actual version of dirt poor
[Laughter]
i got a headache eat some dirt yeah man
you don't need a band-aid all right we
just got some mud for you just put on
put a little bit of that sewer water
water on that and that dirt over there
and it'll get all like wet and stuff you
slap it on the bottom of their foot but
it came out so it must work it did come
out it's got to be something with the
clutch oh look that's a one that's i
mean that's a one in a million shot you
got a shitty b that's what you got yeah
you gotta you gotta beat with a bad shot
didn't have enough initiative
you got a lazy b okay all right it
didn't go deep enough marty did you get
that guy yeah but not great
[Laughter]
that's [ __ ] insane never been sprayed
by a skunk
i have not no not a skunk porcupine
oh man that's always a towel you get you
get hemmed up you got those needles in
you
ooh that's up you're just gonna go to
the nurse's office with that excuse me
yeah that's all of you that's a rough
one no i've seen some skunks and stuff
like that but i've never no not gotten
close enough where i got sprayed yeah
did you ever have it in school like we
would have you know if you like if
you're at gym class or something or you
like ripped your pants or fell in mud
where you had to go change we had to use
we had to change in the lost and found
at the nurse's office
like from what was there
so like and i remember i would it
happened one time i forget what happened
i don't know if i [ __ ] my pants or what
but i had
something happened
and i was like
i called my dad or something like you
got to come get me like i'm not wearing
these
i'm not sitting here trying on all these
different parts because like at that
time i was a fat kid too so i'm like the
chances of being like a pair of extra
large sweatpants at the elementary
school nurse's office is a stretch i've
been hearing a pair of ball hungers
get me out of here yeah i was asking the
nurse i'm like hey do you have any of
your husband's clothes on
you may be thinking for some reason with
the skunk but real trash
you ever have a deer run through your
high school or anything like that
because we have
we had a [ __ ] deer run through our
high school we had my neighbor's house
it jumped through the front window i
guess it saw itself in the reflection
and [ __ ] dove
it [ __ ] this house [ __ ] you looking at
it
yeah
that's insane [ __ ] it up yeah and they
were so trashy they left the wooden
boards they boarded up the window like
for the night and then i kept it up
there for like three months before they
got it fixed did you ever uh you ever
put on uh you're were you ever the
mascot at any of your school
no you probably were though
yeah what were you what was it was an
eagle
yeah it was like this it was a giant
costume with that had like literally the
talons for rubber feet and everything it
was a legit like proper
proper setup big head everything like
that and i i wore that like uh before i
played basketball i would play
basketball after i was the mascot wait
what
holy [ __ ] jeremiah
you would say you would do the warm-up
like everything yeah yeah
yeah slapping yeah and then you'd be
like all right i gotta go
play basketball yeah yeah did you keep
the costume on when you were playing
he's still got the shoes on the wings
pass me the ball it's like a shitty teen
wolf running down the court watkins can
soar yeah
holy [ __ ] you were the eagles right
you're the eagles in grade school yeah
yeah talk about a go-getter though there
you go there there's a guy that works
hard right there yeah just playing
multiplayer playing both sides of the
ball i think it's not throwing the court
and gets in the paint like a gentleman
yeah yep also did concessions at
halftime
it's also coaching the class above me
it's the weirdest remember the titans
ever
nobody wanted to see this movie
buddy thank you so much for coming in
and sitting down with us yeah we
absolutely [ __ ] love you uh what do
you got coming up you want the folks out
there to know uh check out my podcast
jeremiah wonders and scissor bros on
youtube and i'm at jeremiah stand up on
all social media uh check out me as the
joker on dc superhero girls i post clips
and stuff on my instagram and then i've
got a uh uh stand up on the spot special
that is out on youtube now uh that you
should check out with shane gillis akash
singh uh trevor wallace and ian fidence
and myself and we filmed it in uh moon
tower at uh in austin it was fantastic i
saw it it's great thank you man go check
it out buddy we love you thank you so
much i love you guys thank you what do
you got for him uh just make sure you
remember you subscribe back kevin ryan
covent on all social media uh
get some [ __ ] uh come out to a live
show we'll see you on the road gang we
love you and we'll see you back in the
city peace